Sony and Disney found their way back to the
bargaining table, and a deal has been struck.
Ol' web-head will get at least one more MCU-set
starring vehicle, one that we have a funny
feeling will have the word "home" somewhere
in its title.
These are just a few things you can expect.
Details about Spider-Man's third solo outing
in the MCU are exceedingly slim.
Surprisingly, though, we already know the
film's release date, as it was announced at
the same time that Marvel and Sony went public
with the renewing of their shared custody
deal.
Spider-Man's next web-slinging adventure will
hit the big screen on July 16, 2021, at least,
that's where it's slotted at the moment.
It's possible it could be pushed off to a
later date, for a couple of reasons.
First, Marvel's 2021 slate is already pretty
crowded.
Previously announced to be on tap for that
year are Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten
Rings on February 12, Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness on May 7, and Thor:
Love and Thunder on November 5.
If Spidey 3's release date holds up, it would
mark the first time Marvel has released four
MCU pictures in the same year, which even
the most hardcore fans might see as crowding
the market.
And that's before we even get to that year's
Disney+ output.
Also, that summer will see the release of
another highly anticipated superhero film:
Matt Reeves' The Batman, which hits screens
on June 25.
The Robert Pattinson-starring flick will be
the first Batman solo film in nearly a decade.
While Marvel has every reason to be confident
in the web-slinger's ability to kill it at
the box office, there would be no shame in
rethinking putting him up against the Dark
Knight.
"No, no, no, no.
That's…no, that's definitely not what you
wanna watch."
Plot details for the third MCU Spider-Man
flick have not been divulged, in all likelihood
because the movie is still tangled up in early
development.
We do know one thing, however: life is about
to get even more difficult for Peter Parker.
Spider-Man: Far From Home ended on a heck
of a cliffhanger, with Parker's identity having
been revealed to the public thanks to Mysterio
and J. Jonah Jameson.
In the MCU, Jameson is apparently a conspiracy
theorist vlogger and not a newspaperman, but
he still looks a heck of a lot like J.K. Simmons.
"Here's the real blockbuster.
Brace yourselves.
You might want to sit down.
Spider-Man's name is Peter Parker!"
Of course, we can speculate.
Outside of the third Tom Holland movie, Sony
is continuing to develop its Spidey-related
properties independently of involvement from
Marvel Studios.
At the moment, those projects include Venom
2, Morbius, and Kraven the Hunter,
which recently found a screenwriter in The
Equalizer series' scribe Richard Wenk.
It should be noted that, since the days of
the aborted Andrew Garfield-starring Amazing
Spider-Man franchise, Sony has been keen to
get the Sinister Six, a revolving team of
ol' webhead's greatest nemeses, onto the screen.
"First and final warning.
Stay out of our way."
With all of the "Spider-wheelings and dealings"
that have gone on in recent months, fans could
be forgiven for being a bit confused as to
the nature of Sony and Marvel's relationship
at this point.
Follow us here: Venom, which starred Tom Hardy
and featured exactly no references to Spider-Man,
surprised everyone by grossing over $850 million
worldwide despite lukewarm reviews.
Morbius, a solo vehicle for the "Living Vampire"
and longtime Spidey nemesis which Sony has
on tap for 2020, may very well follow suit.
Both films are part of the thus far Spidey-less
Sony Universe of Marvel Characters.
Everyone knows that the MCU reigns supreme,
so why not engineer a crossover between the
two universes?
In fact, this may very well be what's happening,
and if so, Spider-Man 3 will likely to be
a focal point of the strategy.
No less an authority than Marvel Studios head
honcho Kevin Feige has teased that Spidey
is, quote, "the only hero with the superpower
to cross cinematic universes," and in the
past, he's suggested that Hardy's Venom and
Holland's Spidey could one day meet on the
big screen.
It's all but certain that the two studios
are busy hashing out the details even as you're
watching this, but for now, we'll just have
to wait to see how it all plays out.
One of Spider-Man: Far From Home's biggest
twists came during the flick's post-credits
scene, when it was revealed that the Nick
Fury and Maria Hill we'd seen for the entirety
of the film were, in fact, Skrull impostors
assigned to Parker by the real Fury, who was
busy...well, in space, tending to some secret
mission or another on a ship full of Skrulls.
All of this while being extremely shoe-less.
"Who's got my shoes?"
Jokes aside, this set off a massive wave of
speculation that the flick had been tasked
with doing a bit of heavy lifting in setting
up an MCU adaptation of the Secret Invasion
storyline, in which Skrulls infiltrate the
highest ranks of power on Earth by way of,
you know, imitating everyone.
Remarks made by director Jon Watts seem to
indicate, though, that the twist was actually
his decision, and not a mandate from on high.
This would likely mean that Fury's space jaunt
isn't, in fact, setting up major future developments
for the MCU as a whole, so, could it have
been teasing a continued role for Fury and/or
the Skrulls in the next Spider-Man movie?
For now, it's completely unknown, but our
money is on the superspy returning to Earth
to resume his stewardship of Parker, with
a few interesting stories to tell.
When Sony and Marvel made up, the first question
on fans' minds was the obvious one: for how
long?
All we know for certain is that, aside from
his third solo venture, Spidey will appear
in at least one more Marvel Studios film.
Beyond that, the future is a question mark.
Considering that the MCU and Sony's Universe
of Marvel Characters are finally making overtures
toward recognizing each other's existence,
though, there are a few ways it's likely to
go.
The studios could, as previously mentioned,
find a viable narrative way for the character
to switch cinematic universes.
Or, as Deadline has suggest, they could form
a loose connection, with a kind of "call and
response" aesthetic which would keep the franchises
largely separate, but tangentially connected.
Or, if the two studios can truly see their
way clear to giving the fans what they want,
the two universes could merge, with Sony's
established characters being absorbed into
the MCU.
It seems like a pretty slight possibility,
and it might be, but it also happens to be
the option likely to generate the maximum
amount of box office dollars, so we're going
to go ahead and call it "not impossible."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.